okay for people who are joining this
livestream we are in the late stages of
preparing machine learning functionality
for version 12 of language and I think
today we are simply finishing off
documentation of some functions and
doing what we call knitting which is
connecting functions into pages that
they should be mentioned from okay let's
take a look at rarer problem let's say
[Music]
so how general is rare a probability
does rare a probability work on the
distributions on symbolic distributions
and things yeah I hooked up something
actually the first example is on normal
distribution and so yeah it should work
we should probably with someone inside
istic all teams where we review it may
be that some standout that I didn't
comply probe is a weird here
I could be just please just let's just
do this compute the probability to
obtain a rarer
value
rarest sample error value we have value
than three from a normal distribution
from
oh well that's just such bill do you
have that's I have no idea I know okay
alright so this is a so this is a
general function that we can put on
these pages
has it been connected to CDF I mean it's
connected here to PDF and CDF why isn't
it mostly connected to CDF I mean
honestly I mean it's it's it's
I think it's closer to a PDF than a CDF
like it's so should refer to it here
maybe after hazard function we should
refer to this yep I don't know that it's
relevant
functional things about what those are
actually definitely after probably
expectation it's kind of a it's a sub
case of probability V so I know we could
put it at the end here also in CDF I
think we should put it after probability
okay does it belong with Quantrill as
well a little bit yeah yes
you
should we put it at the very end no I
don't think so well integrate these
things these are I don't know
I think it goes after and covertly yeah
or just just probably still run I don't
know about that someone on our live
stream is asking how to replicate
various forms of general linear model
using neural nets that's a good question
I'd like to know the answer to that to
what combinations of layers are
necessary for a particular form of
regression when for linear regression is
just a linear layer for logistic
regression it's just a linear and the
softmax layer we should put that in
properties in relations for those layers
and for those functions it's a good
suggestion it's a useful thing for
people to see I'd like to see that I
mean it would be useful to see from our
linear model fit how the course what the
correspondence is with them
with the actual I mean I don't know what
the you know how oh my gosh all this
stuff
you know how does linear model fit how
does that fitted model correspond to a
neural network right how do you go from
that data
to the trained neuron that like if I if
I did this with net train for example
what would happen so you have to
separate the X and the y
here I would I would basically some so
what do I do I transpose these that what
you're saying
yep and then you can put yeah no yeah so
I just say rule that um and then I would
say that frame of in the earlier I think
it just works linear layer and these
something just works
does all the information that it needs
though you go to register conversion
linear regression
okay so on so what's this country so
that gives that result so now if I say
value let's say it's a two point three
here
you
my golly gosh same thing it's not
amazing that's cool hey we're gonna put
this example this is if this is a good
example yeah this is very useful and it
will be nice to see how all these
residuals and all that kind of thing fit
in
for this case it will give you a same
result same result I mean up to the
optimizer
okay can I um let's see I don't think I
can find the right place to put it in
here can you can you guys figure out
where to put this in so in relations and
property relations
boy oh boy okay you don't take much risk
for putting it there that's right all
right okay but but then it should be
nested into some other place because
this really is an interesting and useful
example and thanks for the suggestion
Muhammad on the live stream um
am I going examples delimiter um so here
I want to say a linear model fit um well
let's see here we have to show linear
model fit applied to those numbers
yeah um copy the first example
oops why didn't that work put survival
names and so on
let's call my X comma X
um simple um do the same fit using a
neural net with a single linear layout
or should we give this we put this in
there let's put this in there
why don't we just say rule at a tap that
doesn't that work going to work as well
let's be slow in this case but when you
have many features it will be much
faster to user
I mean examples version okay anyway I'm
gonna let you guys knit this correctly
in other places but that was there was a
good suggestion and that's useful and as
a matter of fact another thing we need
to do here is to point this things at
linear layer right I think I should
point to linear layer as opposed to what
do you think I think just point to
linear layer yeah definitely and linear
layer should point back to linear model
fit which of course it doesn't
um okay
ah all right let's go back here Seth on
the live stream says that rare
probability is relevant to survival
function a one-sided p-value is a
survival function
not an unreasonable comment so let's sum
let's see where we going there um that
was our probability does it point to
survival function
No where should it do so should do so
before quantile before you directly
before or just after CDF and let's have
a look at several function I think here
let's again
it's super related it's greater than
okay okay
so where should we put it in the in here
before PDF perhaps yeah yeah and then so
our function will be pretty high into a
probability I think even I don't know
see the earth is scientifically related
survival functions one - CDF self points
out actually I realized oh you know I
put ok I put alternative way of
computing or I'll probably end up ok
let's do some knitting here so let's go
uh see for this one has so many guide
that are in statistics I guess actually
we
shanon's wearily yeah let's do that
okay so here
where are you suggesting putting it here
you suggesting putting it in I'm not
sure if it really belongs here
we don't know how probability oh yeah we
do up here do you think it belongs with
these I think it's really not I don't
think it belongs quite with those random
variables
yeah there it belongs
yes so maybe we put it off too since
it's less well-known than these let's
put it at the end of that list since
people mostly won't know what it is
you
but in the distribution related
functions
yep just next to survival
you
well should we put it above since more
general or should we put it below that
both of those okay how would you
describe it here the same way we didn't
documentation probability three okay so
ever already function and that function
of failure rate also they don't explain
my fiance just probability to generator
error
a rare to obtain a general probability
for a rare
oh yes and yeah that's good for any
event for a rarer than a rarer okay okay
and you had another suggestion here on
random variables
I mean yeah I was mainly looking what
PDF and probability where are we just
put it on that we just that was though
its place we just put it okay so let's
just look at survival function and also
did we put it in a machine learning
place or not we didn't
you
you
you
okay survival function we have things
like reliability analysis which I don't
think is relevant to this okay so I
think rare a probability now gun needs
to go on a machine learning page which
machine learning page and we've really
only got one machine learning page which
we've got to break up at some point soon
yes
but we have the neuron that works Paige
this is an unbelievably complicated page
I don't think it belongs on this page
yet
your networks now
definitely not
you
you
you
and this what it would find anomalies
you go well maybe it's related to anime
take
and for in the context of machine
learning this is fundamental so
isn't it on this platter it is on
well alright let's add it's just a learn
distribution next to learn the truth I
mean did we put lemon already I hope so
probably yeah
to my district row should we put it as a
on just on this line at the end relative
yeah yeah
I mean it's yeah
I think we just need to give people a
fighting chance to find it if they want
it yeah I mean eventually we'll probably
want to break out a separate page for
anomaly detection
when we deal with sequences and so on
I love some way to go
okay
alright what's next computes entrances
there is everything to do is here so you
we could do that I could also maybe give
that to Roger and Jose what what is it
what is that for that spell this is to
return a number whizzing around instead
of just number and so I did the
documentation page like I asked Jose
said yeah I find do it because I assume
it will be in this in this department
eventually
and the reason I did is because only my
function I use it for now so your glut I
think is a ridiculous claim this thing
here
and corresponds to a 2-1 standard
deviation yeah let's just say that
during interval generated typically
corresponds to one standard deviation
whatever that means because you know who
knows what that means yeah I mean this
will obviously be included in things
like fitted the the fitting functions
and so on yeah I think you can place in
many many alright okay so let's take a
look at where this goes
I'm not sure this is going to find a
good guide page on home we all see where
around is number with a certainty that I
heard about exactly
it's where around its supposed to be I
think
okay
generating object with infinity perfect
okay
oops
and fits training etc
well one day yeah
[Music]
uncertainty it's in everything I really
I mean this is okay option to generate
uncertainty in and in any orders are not
any but it's or do you say approximate
computation well let's say in numerical
computation no because that will confuse
me with enough like it's like percent um
in statistical computation actually from
now they're all touristical computation
yeah I understand
okay all right fine we'll say that this
will eventually have to be changed
okay yep learn distribution and by the
way competence from Z I mean you're you
ready to get fine
Lynch Bhushan I think we just have the
team although you didn't look at it
carefully I mean your eyeball it few
times already it's probably fine
yeah you you actually actually suggest
some change now I remember more
at an almost circular definition here
after you raise learn distribution
that's what we do focus if I classify
generates the classical function
no but only after we
definition that says it tries to
classify
true I mean this no actually
um it's true we don't say and anymore
and what it means to learn a
distribution anyway generates
and a proxy
distribution data distribution or
something what what should we say an
approximate distribution I mean its
attempt to infer the you know the
underlying distribution of the examples
which
attempts to represent
the underlying distribution of the
examples given from which the examples
given can be generated or just
underlying distribution from which was
the example distribution of the examples
probably okay we're presenting a show
about represents learned attempts
generates a learned distribution which
attempts to give to be the under which a
model to model
well but it represents it that symbolic
thing represents it
there is an underlying distribution we
just don't know what it is no there
isn't necessarily an underlying
distribution actually there is that that
case I mean the hypothesis that it comes
from a distribution an underlying
distribution for the examples given I
realized we never really stated the
classic hypothesis of machine learning
which is exact its example is sampled
you know independently from each other
things like that
okay I realize maybe I'm right that at
some point yes we should generate some
Landis mission which attempts to
represent an underlying distribution
so we could say each example is assumed
to be independently each of the example
I is okay learn distribution effectively
assumes that each of the example I are
independently are but what are we going
to sell independent we drawn from yes
from their underlying distribution are
independently drawn
for underlying distribution which learn
distribution attempts to infer
what are you using as the keywords for
this creature hmm that is a distinct
lack of keywords do better than that
not many okay well this is a lot density
estimation can I say
generative modeling okay you're gonna
have to fill a bunch of these yeah
it's not really data references it it's
just its distribution I mean what were
but think about specific cases like
images for example and we probably need
things like that
when statistical modeling I'm gonna let
you fill these in yeah yeah okay so now
what is the issue here so the issue is
does learn distribution have the
appropriate
well it's one thing that I forgot to do
is to tell that you can use information
learned oh it's pretty more learned
distribution although we could put it on
learn distribution as well I mean I
could write down I guess okay hold on
what was your concern about what was in
here because this seemed to be
reasonably good to me learned it has
been needed yeah I mean it's limited at
least in the machine learning I don't
know if you want to put it in another
guide page like this just call
distribution sky page we could see where
fine distribution is and follow okay
hold on let's take a look at that first
of all let's check the fine distribution
actually has
you
where should it go here after find
distribution parameters
yeah
okay so hold on
let's find
distribution goes and then miss but when
distribution as well
we showed yes and learn distribution
presently other it deserves it
okay what's data distribution this is
the very similar to learn distribution
okay so let's find out why there's
that's mentioned true odds first of all
check
distribution points to learn
distribution which it does not
this should point to learned
distribution because the distribution is
actually the object okay so where should
that go
probably it's pool at the end yeah
because it's a high dimensional creature
actually okay no
statistical distributions that is yeah
this definitive place
something
objects yeah learned okay I think we
should have a thing here where we say
yeah um and then we can say well learn
distribution general distribution
distribution for any kind of data
now do we want to give any other
functions here yes learn distribution
actually in this page you have both
functions and ok so should we just list
that a separate line here learn
distribution and do we want to have any
of the things like um um
let's see when we turn go thinking like
even predict classified it's alright
let's do this let's do this let's put on
this page learn distribution
and then what about the anomaly
detection things and so on it's very
related yeah I mean this arguably
learned distribution should be at a
higher level in these statistics pages
yes okay so what what else do we want to
put here I mean pretty tough function
it's kind of a distribution actually if
we are talking about distributions here
and classifier function as well it's
just a conditioned okay let's point this
over to machine learning
conditional
you
okay so I don't think this is really an
adequate place for to put this let's see
whether we've got
gosh derives to the school
tribunal
I think you had a system where this goes
I can't tell
yep okay we've got that's okay this was
already done actually those are already
done I was thinking we should put these
two indirect transfer missing but they
were either okay all right Oh Seth on
the live stream has suggests manifold as
a keyword for learned distribution you
know I assume that we point learn
distribution to the dimension reduction
stuff do we yes I think so
I wonder if we go the other way around
though this yeah we didn't do think okay
where should it go
I
after feature extraction have
synthesized music values let's put there
as well
well because where should I go at the
end
no after cluster classifier I think
you
it's one of the application there we
point learn distribution to synthesize
missing value just we do that's a good
name by the way that thanks to ya live
stream to come help spend some time on
it right but I mean people actually
understand what it means which is always
good
ok dimension reduced should we be
pointing that to learn distribution yes
same place after feature extract yeah or
maybe I've talked to as principal
components okay okay so um in here
presumably dimension reduction has
manifold and things like that as
keywords well it seems to why why is
this why Sushma that's a question for
you why are these tentative because Ryan
is supposed to know yeah Philip it's a
project that they're doing of adding
keywords okay what what do we want to
just just manifold to learn distribution
I don't know um
there's gotta be other meanings what's
it I don't know many for learning say
that again
what is this related to the by the
terminus manifolds is that the whole
topological data analysis is that
related to this
you know I mean manifold is really like
I need to dimension reduction right yeah
I'm going to put it in here I don't know
if that's really related but I leave it
as an exercise to figure out whether
that's actually related um dimension
reducer function and we could put link
it to learn distribution which I think
we
who probably do it's the other way
around already we should put that at the
end learn distribution yeah okay
anything else
geralyn's items
so yes it's a text contents basically
should do everything the same as text
case what do you mean should do
everything should be in the same places
all right okay hold on what did we
change and classify we I don't remember
changing anything here classify yeah
it's not change it okay so you want to
go and make sure
contains text kgs also contain yeah and
also check what if I interpretation
defecate oh yes
what's this you that I mean that's a job
documentation page which you never saw
so we just want you to okay let's take a
look at it what was it called
very sorry interpretation you know I'm
planning to try and do entity extraction
on four million emails in my archive
it's gonna work
you
you
no no look verify interpreter
true
if this is the description this is the
wrong name there's an option for that
that verifies the interpretation
verifies that they can be interpreted
right yes verified butterflies that's
very fine but I mean it's actually
removes a wonderful I know I know I know
I know
verifies that results can be interpreted
as entities some diamonds hundred
entities can be interpreted can be
semantically
interpreted
can be interpreted but today using
interpreter is that a true statement I
think so
creativity interpreter removes those
that cannot and drops drops yeah I guess
all of them are using interpreter I
wonder if you have one customer laughs
as the results can be I'm not sure
action actually we wrote down typically
interpreter is used to check even
interpreted form a distillate I think
there was one case it was amusing
but I can't remember exactly
and I got to say this here now isn't
there an hour
of this in if I'm not was taking them in
image identify women both text recognize
what does text recognize do if it
doesn't already have an option for this
it should
it's not like acceptance fresh water
it's what because there's a another
field that it's acceptance threshold
type thing that filter will probably DS
too low
I hope but I think this should say
verify interpretation somehow because
it's not quite the right terminology but
it basically means is this in fact does
language identify succeed texts
recognize yes yes I mean in other words
look can it produce gobbledygook or does
it have to be English right does
language identify have to successfully
say it's English say I'm going to test
recognize with language to English
I see I guess I could be a some point an
extension nothing that will be worth
pointing out to shadi that we now have
this verify interpretation
yep okay so so what are we doing here um
see drops those that cannot
you
you
how did it recognize that as a city if
it isn't a city or is it a city it is a
city then why does it say its failure
this is because we don't have his in our
database but that's silly
I mean how did it recognize that it was
a city if it we don't know that it's a
city because of let's work knows how but
that's ridiculous
I mean that's a stupid example if I
might say so I mean in other words no I
mean that's just a bug in some okay
actually you can infer from context yeah
I mean I mean okay it is a bag of our
database that's true but until we should
as an infinite number of bugs right yes
but we shouldn't use as an example
something which is only there because
it's a bug
and I don't understand why it's a bug I
mean what what type of a city is that
why on earth wouldn't it be that this is
too small city I think no doesn't die I
don't believe that I don't believe that
that claim because I think um the let's
take a look here I mean yeah this is the
main source of problem okay what's wrong
with this it's an hour long this small
is it a city or rhythm to the city I
don't think it's a city yes yes yes the
city
I don't know this tea very well but yon
des let's see okay listen listen I tried
some places in England that the recent
way that we don't seem to have but it's
complicated what they really are you
know in the u.s. there's a much better
definition of what cities are I know
France has very precise data on all of
these different administrative divisions
well okay it is a city I mean what does
he mean it's a city
look listen we have a definite
definition of what city is for our
interpreter and for instance you know
like to take a more you know a bigger
example like Singapore happens to be
both a city a state and a country yeah
it is what's happening here
it's a city but it's also I own this
wrong and that's what this thing is
picked you know from afar I think there
was a city is meeting
I don't believe you I think it I bet
what I bet if you dig into this you will
discover that at some level of you know
municipal government structure thing is
Rhonda small but it's not then it is I'm
on the Wikipedia page
it's I don't know why we didn't grab
that but it's a communal and coming our
synonym to city what exactly do you mean
it's a synonym you see this is where
this is where it's gonna get squiggly
okay it's got a Cathedral house it
doesn't have a thick Cathedral the
terminal Cathedral French French French
definition it isn't
it's a yeah
I don't know and what does it say the
population is in there it's saying four
ninety seven hundred and here we're
saying much larger one possibly because
we're dealing with the region so I don't
understand that that's a question for
the curation team um
which we should look into because it
mirrors some issues that I've seen
recently with some English places that
look back in my day we called villages
but I haven't a clue what they're you
know what their status is in terms of
all I know and I was mentioning this to
Alan yesterday what a few days ago is
when you drive into those places they
say welcome to blah blah blah on a sign
so if that's your definition of cityhood
than their cities um okay but this is
really a bad example I wonder I mean
okay we should try to look for other
examples why don't you ask Eurasian
probably why don't we think about a case
where where it really will be true that
we think it's something but it isn't
interpretable where where it has the
19th century okay yeah for example if
you look a date and you say it was
billed in Toulouse in the nineteenth
century
I think 19th century cannot be
interpreted as a date object well that's
not that that's not really true it
absolutely can be just doesn't happen to
be look date object
you know 1919 century let's say 18
what's that century okay he's a
interpreter doesn't work on there noise
yet but that's that's a minor temporary
thing that's about to get fixed yeah
okay yeah we could look for some wait a
second wait is that what is verify
interpretation really
because what you've what it's got to be
really is the neuron that learnt certain
things which interpolated certain things
so you know what's a more realistic
example I don't believe they're going to
be examples in cities but there could be
examples and things like units where the
thing makes no sense
like for instance okay and this may be
incorrect but I mean negative value of
kelvins of temperature mmm would make no
sense but and and we would probably know
that at the level of interpretive but we
will not know that at the level of the
neural net I think this is a problematic
function I have to say I think that what
makes sense is for example in texts
recognize you know whether language
identified correctly says it's English
that makes sense because texts recognize
could validly recognize a sequence of of
things without I mean look let's just
look let's just look here for a second
okay so um let's take a Wikipedia page
it is a very useful aprender now people
have been asking for it for a while and
in actually you've been pushed right as
well I understand I understand so let's
look at Wikipedia data for Toulouse
um and let's now ask for um so let's say
text cases string comma city is that
right yep and I say arrow entity or not
I just said interpretation
how does it know how many seconds are
remaining who's looking at the length of
the piece yes okay all right so now if I
say city arrow entity how does our
entity whoops what distance no its
interpretation
you
you
in here you have some that will stay as
string actually a level hold the pink
city actually refers to tools like the
Windy City does for okay so that's a
curation hello again that's a curation
I'm Paris only as an airport it could be
okay
we can see okay there's two functions
removing the creation arrow but actually
also held things in your network because
sometime we are just wrong like a gloomy
as snow is not a city so the network is
wrong but if you put verify
interpretation it will make sure that it
has been kind of vetted by our database
how an electable are known that have
concluded that collaboration is a
Saturday I don't know I don't know
because because the context and they
live in you know I don't know
right well then so that's a more valid
reason I mean we've got to explain the
verify interpretation I mean yeah we
this is a really bad example if I might
say so okay I'll talk to and we can talk
again about this when Jim is present I
think okay but I think we've got to make
be clearer here that verifies the
results can be interpreted um okay I
think we've got to say here something
about how yeah I mean by the way it's
really an interesting curation task to
go through like things like you know
random web pages and so on and do a
Commerce City thing then do City arrow
interpretation and see what fails yeah
yeah and then everything that's here is
either buggin than your own net or a bug
in our interpreters I think there was a
nice interaction between the six keys
and related tasks we're doing and right
well let's just do this why don't we
just take why don't we take five million
pages from like Wikipedia you just do
this on them with each of the different
interpretations because everything
that's a string here is some kind of
error I mean either it takes KC's oh
yeah right either its text cases or it's
the interpreter one of the one of the
other is wrong mm-hmm for something like
City I think it's much less obvious as I
say for something well I just don't know
how sophisticated interpreter is without
for example- kelvins and things like
this I mean why don't we try what's
another what another thing here let's
try date our interpretation
by the way how fast is our entity
extractor relative to other people's
entity extractors this is hard to say
because depending on takings they use I
mean if you're just spending type things
very fast you go you're the century then
I yeah alright so this is I mean again
this will hopefully get precisely dealt
with in fact you should send Sushil if
you could send this to I guess it's I
guess is it Jeremy Michelson or is it
Owen who's the right person for this
send it to both of them there's an
example of stuff that should parse well
that's a weird one you see that's a bug
in the neuron that BC shouldn't be I
mean I'm sure that goes with one of
these things here
let's call them okay I mean this is
really quite nice quite nice I mean and
now if I take this okay so if I say
interpretation here and now I say and
this would probably be the exam para
fine interpretation arrow true then I
will only get the things that are
actually genuinely yeah I mean
programmatically it's an ISO of that or
and then has to do K Z's and blah blah
blah right so if I now say time line
plot of this
okay cool
so a lots been happening in Toulouse
wherever this was recently 1200 as well
okay
um okay all right I think we should wrap
up here unless you had another thing you
need what was the thing you wanted to
tell you oh you want to map to knit you
know what I'm gonna have to go soon but
but talk to knit oh yes yes yes we have
a couple of questions on live streaming
to do that because Thicke is just they
can't xkz than we I don't think it's
necessarily correct let's take a look at
it um um questions on the live stream is
there a way to use interpreter with your
own entity store I believe that is being
worked on um and the sushma there will
be a good question to ask Tony I know we
discussed it and I don't know whether
it's an active project at this point I
mean the main issue is to be able to add
PLI linguistics PLI style linguistics to
an entity store that's that's a little
bit non-trivial because it's got to go
through this is patched wolf now for
interpreters to actually execute the PLI
if it's non-trivial in other words if it
includes if it's if it is part of the
grammar rules system if it's part of
this system and it includes a
non-trivial token then it's got to
basically call the Wolfram Alpha stack
in order to resolve these things
but the fact is some of these pieces
like fixed order any order all these
things all these things that aren't a
grammar token can be done locally but as
soon as you have a grammar token so for
example you were asking about Pope's
like Benedict the sixteenth if you say
oh four sixteenth I might want Roman
numerals that will become a grammar
token that has to loop through the full
stack right now to get interpreted but
if you say it's literally you know if
you define that grammar yourself or it's
a literal one six or you know XVI or
something then it'll be okay um anyway
so check with Tony because I know we
talked about that okay and Mohammed on
the live stream asks can you include
example how to import orphan language
train network using a neck snap format
into Python including parameters I think
you have the wrong group of people on
this call to discuss that um the answer
is there are supposed to be workflows
that show how to do export of neuron
that's um through our max net into
various kinds of harnesses but I don't
know the full details of that um okay
let's let's take a look at
let's see we're looking for text we're
looking for text cases there's the
places where it appears so text analysis
I don't know what the text normalization
is really what we would want for um see
text cases I don't think that's really
what we want
I don't know seems less relevant to text
normalization sue okay
so let's go look at these other ones
text
analysis sure it's relevant definitely
okay let's take a look
okay um
ruch we put it here and we would say so
what should we say
[Music]
generator data set
you
of
contents
of elements
in a data set of all identified elements
in text of identity all yeah yeah
you know I feel like this goes in a
different place
content extraction it's more like text
pausing isn't it
you
passing I mean yeah no way I try to
target with everything
yes
but it still X track and I see it's not
really extraction
mmm it's not really that either missing
me - um yeah it's kind of content
you
you
you
you know what content analysis yes and
maybe with content analysis could I be
the title for both a structure and text
contents
which note passing but well no but I
think we do want to talk about parsing
that we didn't want to make sure that
text structure points to text contents
which it does and just text contents
point to text structure this more likely
it does not it's rare than the new paid
and in the old page as the link right
nothing anyone oops
yes okay right that goes to text
structure um
okay
yeah I think we're done well let's just
check we have got all the other pages
here processing textual data what's that
it's yeah I mean you don't extract the
text it's not accept that I said it's
not the same thing
oh wait natural producing takes
structure
oh that is the same thing though
you
okay
you
okay I think that's reasonable yep okay
I will push all these changes verify
interpretation needs better example yep
convey that to Jean right and we need to
do that loop with them it's really
really really going to be useful so the
the NLU NLP yeah we are yeah we're in
communication with Anne's team and
that's what you meant
mm-hmm yeah you know just I mean
basically both sides can learn yeah yeah
enjoy as good relation with with them so
that's good okay we should really really
push on it each of these categories
because we're gonna get lots of good
stuff for it
okay thanks to everybody on the
livestream thank you all see you later
bye